want to
take the opportunity to celebrate and
congratulate my friend my colleague my
partner in truth corrine john pierre the
next white house press secretary first
as you all know she will be the first
black woman the first out lgbtq plus
person to serve in this role
which is amazing because representation
matters
that's right people
representation matters and i hear
i'm representing you sane people i'm
dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message it's monday may 9 2022
and that was jen sucky
and she was introducing
her replacement
who is going to be the chief liar she
says her partner in truth her job is to
lie and she has done it more than anyone
on the planet earth for the last year
and a half and she will now be replaced
by karine jean-pierre
we know nothing about her other than the
most important things she's a black
lesbo and for that she's got the gig
very exciting she's also
married to a cnn anchor yes you can't
make this stuff up she is married to
suzanne malveaux who is a cnn anchor i
did not know suzanne is a lesbian not
that there's anything wrong with that uh
but you'd think that perhaps in terms of
optics if you were bringing in
a new
white house press secretary you could
maybe possibly
find someone who wasn't married to a cnn
anchor do you think that would be
possible
but the impossible is possible with
these people anyway we are live
streaming on rumble on blaze tv and on
youtube do me a favor and subscribe
wherever you're watching tap that
notification bell and the theme
of the program today is that the left is
completely bananas and the media is
either tacitly endorsing it or actually
pouring
fuel on the fire obviously this whole
roe v wade and the leaked brief
uh is out there and people are starting
to protest and show up at supreme court
justice houses and a whole bunch of
other stuff and we are going to have to
figure out when i say we i mean those of
you that are my partners in truth we are
going to have to figure out how
do we pave a new path as these people
continue to burn down our institutions
whether they're the judiciary the
supreme court whether they are
all of our media institutions which are
crumbling and are just going to add fuel
to the fire as i just said we just have
to figure out how we're gonna go ahead
and uh and build new things and thrive
it's in the subtitle right over there uh
reminder guys real quick i'm heading
back out on the road on wednesday i will
be in brea california with dennis prager
you know this guy dennis prager from
prageru we're going to be there there's
a couple seats left we sold out all 500
seats that somehow they added 70 seats
they figured it out to jam more people
in there the 12th i'll be in oxnard with
larry elder 15th i'll be in san jose
with douglas murray 16th phoenix with
blake masters who's going to be the next
senator from arizona as well as charlie
kirk from turning point usa brian callan
is joining me may 18th at the gothic
theater in denver colorado and then i'm
back here for a little bit before we
wrap this thing up with this guy you may
have heard of him ron desantis governor
ron desantis of the free state of
florida at the plaza live june 2nd in
orlando in disney country that's what
we're doing
yada yada all right guys before we get
started real quick i want to talk to you
about healthy cell you know have you
ever wondered if those vitamins you're
taking every day are actually working
for you more than 240 million americans
take supplements in daily pill form but
they usually don't get the promise
results because they don't absorb the
nutrients properly what if i told you
there's a new type of dietary supplement
one that will absorb into your body far
better i want to tell you to check out
healthy cell it's a new ingestible gel
that not only tastes great but has 165
percent more absorption absorption than
pills it uses a new technology called
micro gel to deliver maximum absorption
those old-fashioned tablets capsules and
powders contain synthetic other
ingredients ever wonder what those are
it's things like binding glues fillers
and coatings that can irritate the
lining of your stomach healthy cells
micro gel on the other hand suspend
soluble ultra absorbable nutrient
particles inside a natural gel made of
gut healthy ingredients like soluble
fiber citrus pectin acacia gum and more
and water why not it doesn't contain
artificial sweeteners flavorings or
colorings heck it's even non-gmo
gluten-free and vegetarian just visit
healthycell.com and use code ruben for
20 off your first order that's
healthycell.com and use code r-u-b-i-n
reuben for 20 off your first order and
now back to me all right so obviously
the big story of the last you know week
and a half or so has been this leak of
the briefing samuel alito's briefing on
the reversal of roe v wade and the
protests are starting and the violence
is starting and unfortunately we don't
have a trusted class or a media class of
people that are willing to tell these
people to sit down you can protest
peacefully but you can't show up to
people's houses and you certainly can't
be violent so just to get you fully
caught up to speed we've got some info
here from the daily wire
leftist organizations have called for
abortion supporters to demonstrate at
the homes of conservative supreme court
justices one of these groups ruth sent
us is also calling for protesters to
stand at or in a local catholic church
on sunday mother's day that was
yesterday obviously on its website ruth
sent us had posted a map that listed the
street names where each justice
supposedly lives with their families amy
coney barrett john roberts samuel alito
brett kavanaugh clarence thomas and neil
gorsuch but the map no longer appears on
the root sent us website a review by the
daily wire found and as of 6 pm on
friday a google message says this map is
no longer available due to a violation
of our terms of service and or
policies okay so what you've got here
are groups of people who are now willing
to show up to supreme court justice's
houses now if you do that obviously you
are trying to intimidate them and not
only are you trying to intimidate them
you're trying to scare their kids you're
trying to scare their spouses they live
in normal residential areas
so you are also intimidating the
neighbors you are trying to generally
create an unsustainable environment over
time but people did show up outside
supreme court justice kavanaugh's house
and you'll see he lives in a very
normal
decent area just probably like you live
in and here are the people outside his
house
okay so you've got protesters there they
did not get violent so okay i'm not
going to overstate this more than it
should be
but the general idea that you'd have
websites abortion activist websites
leaking their addresses we live in a
very polarizing time
uh do you think that someone might take
it upon themselves to do something that
should not even be mentioned something
really bad whether it's to the justice
themselves or one of their family
members or whatever this is all
completely designed to intimidate people
and what's messed up about this beyond
the obvious part that's messed up is
we're not even talking about the leak
anymore i i was searching this morning
looking for anything over the weekend is
anyone doing any research on where this
leak came from it doesn't seem like it
is you can see conservative sites are
like well what happened here had this
thing get leaked et cetera et cetera
there's there's no call in the
mainstream media
there's nothing at the biot
administration as to who leaked this
thing and it's very clear that this
thing was leaked
because they wanted just this to happen
this is their soft
mostly soft i would say but it's not
fully soft this is their soft
justification
of these mobs and also let's not forget
these are the same people who two years
ago were rampaging through our streets
and burning down buildings and stopping
people on highways etc etc so these mobs
basically do the grunt work they are the
pawns of the democratic party they are
the pawns of the mush of the machine
these are the same people who invaded
the supreme court when brett kavanaugh
was being put in to the supreme court
right after he was sworn in and the days
leading up to it remember then they
literally burst into the supreme court
that wasn't an insurrection though
because they're good guys you know those
are the good guys that we got over there
they're not like those scary trump
insurrectionists uh but anyway the the
theme of the show today is just that
what are we gonna do as more and more of
this leaks into the streets as the
administration
sort of says it's kind of okay to do as
the media tells you it's pretty much
okay to do
how are we going to get through all of
this i'm going to talk to you about that
right after one more ad guys i want to
talk about real estate agents i trust
you know buying or selling a home is
already one of the most stressful things
you can do and it can be 10 times worse
if you're not working with a great agent
generally speaking our homes are our
biggest investment i know they are for
me and that's a lot of responsibility
and you need an agent who can take that
seriously that's why i recommend real
estate agents i trust founded by my by
my good buddy glenn beck they work with
only the best agents in every market
they do their homework talking to every
agent before inviting them to join their
network and here's a big one they only
work with full-time professionals no
part-time or inexperienced agents their
team makes the intro and then follows
you through the buying or selling
process to make sure that you're
satisfied partnered with the blaze the
agents they work with have a long track
record and are the best sellers in their
field they're part of this audience they
share your values and they're almost
anywhere you want to go particularly
florida the process is simple just go to
real estate agents itrust.com today and
provide us with some basic info that's r
e a l e s t a t e agents i trust dot com
their team will contact you to make an
intro to their preferred agent in your
town and now back to me okay
so it's not just that you've got some
foot soldiers out there and again you
are allowed to protest you can't protest
in the middle of the street okay you
shouldn't be going to people's homes i
have never liked that and and
there may be some gray area this is what
i've heard a few people say there's a
little bit of a gray area whether you
can protest outside peaceful people's
homes now if you do it peacefully
outside people's homes
i think some of this is left up to the
local laws but we just have to realize
what are we unearthing what are we
unearthing and let's let's do a reverse
version of the video that i just showed
you let's say that was a bunch of
right-wingers
right-wing people protesting outside the
house of a lefty justice say sotomayor
let's say there was a bunch of them that
weren't happy with her decision and they
were outside we'd be being told that
they were terrorists that they were all
right they were being instigated by
scary people like tucker carlson or dave
rubin et cetera et cetera but now it's
going to basically be excused and if you
don't believe me well here's that gen
socky woman and this is jensaki on
friday
basically saying yeah you guys can do
whatever you want outside of his house
these activists posted a map with the
home addresses of the supreme court
justices is that the kind of thing this
president wants to help your side make
their point
look i think the president's view is
that there's a lot of passion a lot of
fear
a lot of
sadness from many many people across
this country about what they saw in that
leaked document we obviously want
people's privacy to be respected we want
people to protest peacefully if they
want to to protest that is certainly
what the president's view would be so he
doesn't care if they're protesting
outside the supreme court or outside
someone's private residence i don't have
an official u.s government position on
where people protest i want it we want
it of course to be peaceful and
certainly the president would want
people's uh privacy to be respected but
i think we shouldn't lose the point here
the reason people are protesting is
because women across the country are
worried about their fundamental rights
that have been law for 50 years their
rights to make choices about their own
bodies and their own health care are at
risk that's why people are protesting
they're unhappy they're scared
all right so you guys get it she's
excusing it but she had the word butt in
there right so she is absolutely
excusing and she's saying they have to
be peaceful and that's good so she's not
like outright calling for people to be
assassinated or decapitated and she's
claiming she's for privacy but she is
for it now remember
it's just so obvious like imagine if
this was ruth bader ginsburg's house if
she was still alive and they were
right-wing protesters do you think
gensake would be up there saying oh well
we just want them to be peaceful and
people are upset and they you know they
have a right to do it like it's just
pure it's pure pure pure pure pure
unadulterated bs that's what it is and
you can see this so what happens is the
lies and the obfuscation of the truth
they get laundered through the
administration and then they get out
through the washington post and the new
york times and cnn and msnbc and
everywhere else here's a opinion piece
in the washington post this is what they
had to say about
protesting outside people's houses the
decisions by supreme court justices have
a direct impact on people's lives such
as the case of texas senate bill 8
denying health care to millions of
pregnant people pregnant people in texas
we used to call them women women back in
my day old school the consequences of
supreme court justice brett m
kavanaugh's actions will be dire and
having protesters outside his home for
one night pales in comparison with what
he and his fellow conservative justices
have inflicted on pregnant people in
this country i mean this person who
wrote this piece is a complete clown
she can't say women she can't say women
and also one night of protests well we
know these protests are going to
continue but the fact that they can't
say women and we just brought in a new
supreme court justice who also can't
decide what a woman is right she's not a
biologist we are they're just dragging
us to the endless descent to hell but
don't worry guys you know me we're going
to have solutions here
but
you can't do this it doesn't matter if
it's one night or two nights also
they're not attacking women's rights
they're just kicking it back to
the states that's all that they're doing
and if you want to get an eight-month
abortion if you love baby murder you can
go to california and gavin newsom will
probably pay you extra for it
here's some crazy person uh on cnn
defending protesting outside justice's
homes and and this is a question about
civility the frustration people feel is
personal but where's the line obviously
what we see the the apparent arson at a
uh at an anti-abortion nonprofit in
wisconsin is over the line violence is
always over the line but the real
questions and conversations today about
protests outside supreme court justice's
houses particularly justice kavanaugh um
where do you think that line is i think
for a lot of people the a conversation
about civility feels um like it misses
the mark when constitutional rights that
you believe that you had for over 50
years are about to be overturned the
justices have security so far all the
protests have seemed overwhelmingly
non-violent uh there are plenty of
protests that happen every single day in
this country around the country at
abortion clinics blocking women from
getting into clinics and we don't cover
those as if there's four alarm fires and
so yes they're going to be protests in
front of kavanaugh's house because
people are angry um and as long as they
stay non-violent i think for most for
most of the people who are watching it
you can understand where they're coming
from even if you may think politically
it's not the right thing you can
understand sort of where that animated
feeling is coming from
it's interesting trickery what they do
there first off the host he says
particularly kavanaugh now they're
really focusing on kavanaugh this is the
guy that for what four months they
pretended was the biggest serial rapist
of all time
cnn and washington post and new york
times and the rest of it they ran story
after story a story how he was
gang raping and endlessly raping girls
in high school and college there was
never any evidence of it none of it ever
turned out to be true but now they're
still particularly focused on him we
can't let go of the fact that we made up
he was a rapist we better send people to
his house and then the woman there what
she's doing is she's playing both sides
right because it's sort of like don't be
violent and they have protection and
these people are peaceful except do you
realize what the slippery slope here is
the slippery slope is everyone can have
a reason to protest at someone's house i
could watch that video and be like well
who is that lady she's a public person
she's on cnn i don't like what she said
i'm gonna set up a tent outside of her
house and i'm gonna get this guy and
that guy and that guy and they're gonna
come with me guys we're not going to
lunch today no lunch for you guys we're
protesting out that woman's house okay
you see the point everyone can be upset
about something everyone can find
something to be morally indignant about
everyone can be upset that a supreme
court decision happened or a law got
passed or whatever once we decide as a
society
that will be what will become part of
our fabric part of our national
discussion will be that if you don't
like someone you will find their address
and camp outside their house and yell
and scare their kids on their way to
softball et cetera et cetera then we got
a real problem
but ladies and gentlemen there are some
sane voices believe it or not they're
not democrats but there are some sane
voices senator ted cruz from texas who
has been extremely consistent on
protesting which you're allowed to do
like i think he's a constitutional
lawyer if i'm not mistaken um yeah he is
uh he is actually making some sense when
it comes to how you can protest but you
can't be violent and the rest of it
we've got left-wing groups now that have
published the addresses of justices the
intent of this clerk was to bully and
threaten and intimidate the justices to
changing their votes and i got to say
this week it was shameful that the white
house refused to condemn violent
protesters threatening the families of
the supreme court it is disgraceful and
joe biden used to be chairman of the
judiciary committee joe biden knows it's
disgraceful he's literally threatening
the lives of these justices by the mob
they're unleashing it's the same thing
we saw with black lives matter and
antifa riots where the left embraced
them and now they're embracing mob
violence to get their their partisan
outcome it's good to see cruz fired up
sometimes right because he's absolutely
right this is the same thing you really
got to understand the the blm stuff the
antifa stuff although we haven't seen
buildings burning down yet and mass
we're going to show you some violence in
just a sec
but although we haven't seen that in
mass
they use these young people that they
send out into the streets to intimidate
people whether it's protesting outside
someone's house or burning down the
local target and pep boys what did that
boys ever do to you
this is how they get their movements to
feel
like they're important oh look at all
these young people out on the streets
and young people can be out on the
streets in the middle of covet if it's
for that but if you know trump does
something it's a super spreader yada
yada yada yada
and of course once again they've got the
media to protect them and encourage them
the entire time
here is cnn claiming that the violence
is really going to come from the right
officials are preparing for potential
violence
in the capital and nationwide after the
leak of that supreme court draft opinion
that would strike down roe v wade after
50 years capitol police are warning the
far right is calling for violence
against a religious group planning to
rally for abortion rights law
enforcement sources several of them tell
us that they are closely monitoring
social media chatter
that suggests that there's a potential
for violence against abortion clinic
providers abortion clinic staff members
of the judiciary that would include the
justices here as well as members of the
federal government and what we know
after january 6 and what law enforcement
knows across the country is that social
media chatter can manifest into actual
violence sometimes people really do say
what they're going to do
social media chatter that's the worst
kind of chatter yeah
social media chatter there are people
online saying things and guess what if
you say mean things and you're
chattering online and you're saying
illegal things they're gonna get you but
this is pure fear-based nonsense they
are focused on social media somebody's
on a phone with a thing
they're focused on that to make you
think that right-wing people
so just try to understand the logic here
right wingers who are happy that roe v
wade is getting reversed so it's going
to go back to the states and then you'll
either live in a state that has abortion
or doesn't have abortion or has some
combination of some term of abortion etc
etc they are going to start attacking
the abortion people there is literally
no evidence of this but right shatter
they're chatting
so okay so these people are chatting so
so but uh so let it be they're chatting
okay it's very scary the chatters um but
there as far as we know has been no
violence we did find uh a pro-life
center that had a molotov cocktail
thrown at it yeah look at this this is a
pro
life center where is this guys
get me the location on this one but
literally had a molotov cocktail this is
not the middle east
uh right this is not uh afghanistan this
is not somewhere this is in wisconsin
okay a pro-life center molotov cocktail
destroyed so this was left wing violence
at a pro life center but as i always say
we got to give the devil as do we got to
do some research i'm sure
we can find some with all this chatter
that's out there guys i'm sure we could
find some right wing terrorism
couldn't couldn't find anybody i like
that cricket let's play the cricket
again
there's your right wing that's what
right-wing chatter sounds like we here's
right-wing chatter for you one more time
chatter
but then
i've shown you a lot of cnn today
there's this uh televised mental
institution known as msnbc and they had
this woman this i mean these people are
all bananas just look at these people
they're all just nuts but they have this
woman amy hagstrom miller and now no
matter what i'm about to show you of
this woman i don't think you should show
up to her house but by their own by
their own rules you could show up to her
house if you don't like what she's about
to say but listen to this just bananas
psycho
lunatic crackpot
yeah
amy you just heard michelle refer to uh
the anti-abortionists as terrorists and
she has a point because the
quote-unquote people who call themselves
pro-life um they achieve this through
violence there is violence and it is
terrorism and i think it's very
important for us to recognize that it is
christian extremism that is at the root
of the shame and the stigma
that allows laws like this to pass that
allows justices like this to be uh
confirmed and this does not represent
the majority of feelings and beliefs of
people in this country everybody knows
and loves somebody who's needed an
abortion in their lifetime
yes the pro-life terrorists the people
who are trying to save the babies are
the terrorists you want to rip children
eight-month fetuses out of women and
then gouge on their eyeballs with gavin
newsom and have your abortion parties
those
could we raise the baby maybe figure out
a place maybe we'll put the baby in
abortion and put the baby in adoption
we'll figure out something no those are
the crazy terrorists but of course it's
the christians it's the cr these people
are insane but remember by their rules
you out there watching this could find
her address it could be posted on some
website and sit outside of her house and
scare her children is she married i
can't believe imagine anyone would marry
her that she has kids herself who would
want to be part of that
but i would not be for that that
is the point that is the point but what
they are doing is they are trying to
ratchet up the fear fear all the
democrats have they've wrecked the
economy supply chain gas prices
inflation ridiculous war
in ukraine all of this stuff they've
done the border all the stuff that we
talk about all the time right they've
done so much bad that they need the only
thing they've got is fear and anger and
we're going to live in
this time where they're going to be
coming for women and it's going to be
like the handmaid's tale and blah blah
blah blah
well here's nancy pelosi and uh you know
she's using her scare tactics although i
will give nancy a little credit whatever
work she had done over the last couple
days they seem to have done the fillers
right she's looking a little better than
usual right now instead of people going
off on what
the
republicans would like us to talk about
the leak no we're talking about
your life
the life of women in our country and how
we have uh again a calibration of all of
this in roe v wade and how we must have
it be enshrined as the law of the land
this is a severe danger
to women it's a severe danger to the
constitution of the united states and
it's a sphere of danger to other rights
of privacy that are in the constitution
okay none of that is true it is not a
danger to women guys i'm not a
mathematician but i think about half
people are women that means half of the
babies are women so you're kind of
protecting some of the women again this
doesn't even matter what you think about
abortion but the fear they're coming for
women they're coming for privacy they're
coming for the constitution this is the
constitution working the constitution
working is constitutional supreme court
justices looking at the decisions and
making the appropriate decision you may
not like it and again i say this knowing
that most of my audience right now most
of my audits how many people that are
that are on youtube or twitter or
cnn or elsewhere
would say something that is directly
contrary to their audience but most of
my audience is pro-life i know that for
sure
i am begrudgingly pro-choice at least
for a few weeks i would say 12 weeks
you've got three months and i just
believe that there is a fundamental
difference between the cell splitting
and the form and the and the brain
activity and the heartbeat and all of
those things it's not to deny its life
you guys know my spiel on this thing uh
but we could have an honest discussion
about that we could have an honest
discussion about 15 weeks that florida's
doing and florida passed the 15-week
thing and nobody cared nobody cared
because it shows you that pro-life
people as as personal
and as closely as they hold their own
religious beliefs about the nature of
life like the most existential stuff
they're they're showing but we're
willing to live in a society that has
some room for margin right that has some
ability to some people are going to do
some things we don't like what we don't
want is eight month abortion so florida
did 15 they passed this a few weeks ago
nobody cared i can't say nobody cared
but it was allowed to pass without major
fanfare because most people saw that as
a decent compromise but florida will now
be painted and of course ron desantis
will now be painted as these crazy
right-wing extremists because these
people lie about everything and here is
another crazy person this is one of the
members of the squad don't worry it's
not aoc or ilhonomer
this is ayanna presley she is completely
these people
are just
bananas
we have got to codify roe v way we
should
abolish the filibuster
it is clear that this supreme court
continues to obstruct the will of the
people because majority of americans
um support roe v wade do not want it
overturned and the far-right extremism
of this supreme court has obstructed the
will of the people when it comes to
voting rights when it comes to housing
rights and now when it comes to
reproductive freedom justice in bodily
autonomy so if you're not outraged you
are not paying attention you know the
fact that 50
of those who call this country home
uh could have our rights taken away from
us our bodily autonomy and uh
be forced
to birth
with all of the other many uh layered
legislative systematic oppression and
denials and everything and then we have
not yet to uh enact uh parentally paid
leave we do not have universal child
care we have a black women experiencing
the highest rates of maternal morbidity
and now forced birth and we know that it
is our most vulnerable our most
marginalized um the disabled low-income
uh women of color african american
indigenous the our lgbtqi
a siblings who will be the most
vulnerable to this we have to legislate
organize mobilize as if lives depend on
it because they do
what you just saw there was a mishmash
of all of the buzzwords all of the
meaningless phrases all of the conflated
and confused ideas of what a progressive
is
of course this is a far right this is a
far-right court because anything that
happens that you wouldn't like is far
right and what she means by that is
racist and then of course she tells us
how we're all systemically racist and
that we're forcing black women to have
kids that's the worst thing you can do
to a woman force a woman to have a kid
who's pregnant that would oh my god
they're gonna have a kid they got
pregnant they're gonna have a kid that
is that is just the workforce
to birth it's the far right extremism of
the
it's all meaningless dribble and then
when she's talking about it and child
pay and all of these things it's like
those are the big government programs
you want that has nothing to do with how
we're governed it has nothing to do with
the laws of the united states and one
more time guys by the way this idea of
packing the court that is an assault on
the constitution we have three branches
of government i know that your wizard
aoc does not know that but we have three
separate branches they have checks and
balances to make sure none gets too
powerful so if you use your power to
overpower another branch you are in
violation of your oath of office start
impeaching these people i'm not kidding
they're telling you we hate america we
hate the founding documents we want to
assault the constitution
that's the thing that they swore on most
of them i think ilhan swore on a on a
koran but most of them swore on on the
on the bible right but you're really
supposed to
in my view you should be swearing on the
constitution more than anything else
because that's the thing that actually
you're sworn to uphold
but but these people are all bananas and
now here's the warning connor do we have
the warning for the people can we show
them the warning we've got the warning
okay
um
what you're about to see here is pure
[ __ ] look at the bottom right there
we're warning you guys because it's
important that we do that we're about to
show you a clip
from a program on abc that's on right
now
and it's called the view
okay but i know this may be a novel
point a novel idea for somebody who's
you know a supporter of trump but there
are people who are capable of being
related
many things that i don't stand by that
trump did trump has done things that are
racism i'm a black woman first so always
understand that but i do say that i have
many conservative values that i will
talk to you about and so if you look at
your network that you're standing behind
yes and when you look at your network
that you're standing behind you're
saying that you look at chris that's an
oxymoron a black republican you feel
like it's an oxymoron i do why your
friend right here is a republican we
have she's not conversation
you do what you say you feel like it's
an option that you're catholic but you
also had a whole life i don't understand
i know you you don't understand yourself
then you you have this i understand
myself i don't understand either of this
but it's not a personal conversation
we're going i don't like we're having a
personal conversation about about cnn i
don't understand how black people and i
don't understand latino republicans
today this is not about me and it's not
about you it's about celebrating karen
john pierre
[Applause]
okay so first off the woman who is
making sense on the panel and someone
can we send her i want can we if we can
find her address i would like to send
her some cookies or flowers or something
her name is lindsey granger
and she was up there defending her
beliefs apparently she's a trump
supporter she's obviously a republican
or a conservative but think how insane
this show is the idea of the view and
i've talked about this a few times
barbara walters created the view so that
they would get all of these women from
different walks of life and different
ages and different ethnicities and
different beliefs so they'd sit at that
table and respectfully talk to each
other and it worked for a certain amount
of time but then it all became lefties
harping and trying to destroy the
conservatives just ask elizabeth
hasselbeck ask megan mccain now they
don't even have a real conservative
they've got that pretend one who's the
anna navarro who who's obviously a
democrat right like she pretends to be a
conservative but when the woman was like
hey you're a republican she was like
meanwhile people keep telling me i live
like a few blocks away from her i'm
going to see her with my dog one day and
then it's just not going to be good oh
but i'm not for violence i just want to
be clear about that was a joke my dog is
not going to maul anna navarro uh anyway
sonny hostin who is the one sitting
there now now remember they invite this
woman on the show they invite lindsey
graham show to share her views and then
they treat her horribly they are
demeaning and offensive to her it's an
oxymoron to be a black republican it's
an oxymoron to be thomas soul one of the
greatest thinkers ever of the of the
last century it's an oxymoron to be
candace owens it's an oxymoron to be
larry elder or david webb and i don't
even want to just sit here and list
black republicans it's nonsense clarence
thomas etc etc your friend watching this
you watching this perhaps the idea that
your skin color means that you have to
be part of a political party man they
are the bigots they are the racists
understand it
sonny hostin thinks that the color of
your skin dictates how you must think
that is the most racist backwards
pathetic anti-human sentiment that you
can possibly imagine and then she's also
saying if you're a latino so if you're a
latino clearly by the nature
of your ethnicity and your history we
should know what you think about taxes
clearly right if you're black you should
want high taxes and big government
programs clearly because of the color of
your skin if you're black you must be
pro-choice if you're latino you must be
pro-choice it sounds like sonny hostin
wants a lot of people that are very poor
stuck on the government dole with dead
babies i'm pretty sure that's what sonny
hosting wants these idiots by the way
when i saw that clip i offered and i do
stand by this 100 percent uh i offered
to put up if they will put candace owens
on the view to debate sonny hostin i
will donate 10
000
10 000 bucks to the charity of sunny
hosting's choice even a pro-choice
charity whatever she wants uh whatever
she wants uh i will if she will debate
candace owens i'll put up ten thousand
dollars i will also put up five thousand
dollars if they will sit joy on one of
those big tanks of water and i get one
toss of a bean bag one toss of a bean
bag
five thousand dollars i'll do it from 20
feet away i've been practicing uh
outside and i feel pretty good about
what we can do there uh anyway obviously
there are black republicans obviously
there are latino republicans and
obviously there are the scariest of all
things there are gay republicans it's
true
uh but if you want to see
how fake these sunny hostins are these
people who pretend to be for black
people and latino people and everything
else uh here is a spectacular video that
was going viral over the weekend of a
man silencing some blm protesters it's
chefs kiss enjoy lives matter or just
some black lives
the black lives killed by black men
matter right
yes
the black babies killed in the abortions
clinics matter right
thought so the black the black officers
killed by that bastard in minnesota that
matters too right
okay but the black babies that are
killed in the abortion clinics don't
matter do they
medical people
are do their lives matter
does the future of our black babies
matter
huh what's up what's up awful quiet now
aren't they
uh-huh
it's okay if we kill him in the womb
right
but you have a problem when we you don't
seem to really have a problem we kill
them on the streets
yes we know they're the same issue if we
don't if we don't respect the lives of
our unborn children
enough to save them and fight for them
our lives mean nothing once we're born
how awesome is that like that's how you
shut these people up these virtue
signaling
buffoons who have not thought through
any of the issues you know if if the
right wants to do something good right
now you see you remember how the the
left uh took bill hb1557 here in florida
and they turned it into don't say gay
what the left what the rights should be
doing right now what the pro-life
community should be doing right now is
stop calling themselves pro-life just
just start a movement the black babies
black babies matter movement
black babies matter oh you hate black
babies and let's see how racist these
people really are because they are quite
racist guys it's me monday over at the
reuben report locals community here's
what i put up this morning i threw it
was a throwback to elon musk and tesla
which already seems like a long time ago
but elon musk is going to be the ceo of
uh of twitter there and this is just all
the attacks he's getting meanwhile he is
just doing his thing he's just building
tesla he's building twitter he's
building the boring company he's
building spacex neurolink et cetera et
cetera
and a whole bunch of other people have
put some things in there
the locals community was chatting along
during the show which you guys can do as
well reubenreport.locals.com you can
chat on your phone or on your desktop
carpenter says i'm working with a great
agent from your sponsor agents i trust
awesome awesome glenn started this
company a couple years ago they vet
absolutely everybody like these are sane
agents who get it like it's his company
the only other show they're advertising
on is me uh it sounds like they got a
whole bunch of leads and people are
moving all over the country i mean i get
emails literally every day
people flee in new york people flee in
cali so i'm so thrilled if i can help
you guys uh you know basically find
somebody that'll help you find a better
home and a better place to live all of
that stuff oh we got a great cold
clothes for you in just a sec so hang
tight for that b says
i can't tell if the democrats have
double standards or none well i believe
it was the great ronald reagan who said
if it wasn't for double standards the
left would have none so uh yeah it's a
little hard to say it's a little hard to
say uh uh jeannie says i'm gonna be at
your brea show
[Music]
fantastic so it was a 500 seat theater
that's what we were told we immediately
sold it out somehow they've added 70
seats how'd they do it michael we don't
know they're going to jam you people
like sardines so there are a couple
seats left dennis prager's open for me
that's wednesday night
and finally guys uh we got a great cold
close for you very excited about this
one i think we're gonna have to call
back to this one in a future show
because it kind of gets to everything
we're talking about here if we can't
talk about things freely then what do we
have left as a nation
i leave that
to john f kennedy jr
freedom of information
is a fundamental human right
and the touchstone of all the freedoms
to which the united nations is
consecrated
we welcome the view of others
we seek a free flow of information
across national boundaries and oceans
across iron curtains
and stone walls
we are not afraid to entrust the
american people
with unpleasant facts
foreign ideas alien philosophies and
competitive values
for a nation that is afraid to let its
people judge the truth and false in an
open market
is a nation that is afraid of its people